it's a fun thing when you go back and
watch it is you know they're laughing
because they also know the table is
coming on the greatest showmen you
[ __ ] up as you succeeded you can't
sneak apart Howard Stern baby is a waste
of two thumbs Brent's got his package
Brent at the radio Hall of Fame he's
very passionate about the Hall of Fame a
spokesperson so you you're really into
radio Hall of Fame I am I am I think
agreed but I think it should have the
same level or respect with the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame at I think his next
project is he wants Fred to get in I
want Fred in and garyun and the Howard
Stern Show I want Fred in I want Fred
out of here in the seriously you should
be in the Hall of Fame humble look how
unique what the unique thing that Fred
does nobody else in radio does what go
ahead no one wants it nobody wants
so remind people with President may I
mean he adds a layer to this show that's
really incredible
sound effects I love him Fred should be
in the radio Hall of Fame 100% yeah like
Gary played clip 18 JD personality and
he speaks well on the air he's been a
great seducer for a lot of years
interesting stories for the show you
don't have to convince me did I tell you
about the time when I was very young and
I actually was going to maybe going
through the pet supply business store
and I work for them I would sell the
wee-wee pads and they said you know if
we ever open a second store on Long
Island we would like you to orchestrate
things what an accolade
so Fred starts texting me like two weeks
ago I gotta take Gary I've never read
your book I'm gonna read your book and
they're sending me all these texts about
heartfelt things in the book and then I
realize he's reading the book so he has
material to make fun right it's called
research
Gary puppet if you were guy if you
really got into the radio Hall affair
would you have an idea of what you would
say okay we'll talk about my
Thanksgiving dinner oh yeah without
mother see we my mom would cook this
Thanksgiving dinner she would make the
you know the sweet potatoes with
marshmallows and the turkey and the
spaghetti and the meatballs but on a
side table was like a little kids table
she had this little card table and she
would put the artichokes if anyone
deserves to but you know I want to
nominate to the radio Hall is that right
there JD Harmon I'm not kidding you just
to hear his speech but I mean seriously
you're good on the air I mean you know I
mean good bad you know what I mean just
kdeeny choked over a president in there
I'm definitely not afraid you're in my
Hall of Fame Eric do you think my book
is flying off the shelves because of
this right now
yes what was that noise damn Eric is
that you yeah what happened does it hurt
you to get down and your knees not
really and why you make that noise when
he has to put effort into something
Howard right now in this singlet but
he's in a giant scale all right Eric
you're in there they're strapping you in
and now let's begin JD you're gonna load
the books yes all right he's in I mean
are we good
you're gonna do a stack of ten at a time
yeah all right let's keep track everyone
so Howard here comes the first stack
Earth stack you got to see this one
nothing Eric didn't lift at all that's
ten bucks second stack 20 bucks and Eric
hasn't budged
the scale is tipped to the floor third
stack 30 bucks and Eric hasn't budged
off of the floor JD bringing forth JD's
work out four stacks that's 40 you feel
like you're moving at all no all right
fifth stack fit stack I think I'm in big
trouble
I think Fred's looking like a genius
stack number six 60 books and and Eric
has not lifted off the ground Jesus
Christ I'm out of the game my guess was
75 so I'm eliminated here
here comes 80 80 let's see if that 80
books have you moved at all Eric no this
is our first level we can only get 90
books on the first level all right so 90
books are on the scale man why did what
happen I saw a movie I'm not sure here
we go 100 books our tiny bit and moved
to a tiny booth stack number 11 110
volts is coming up right now stay common
110 copies of Howard Stern comes again
close to me now here comes stack number
12 Howard he is off the floor here comes
stack number 13 this would be a hundred
thirty books I said once I'm out of it
130
almost even oh my god you got to watch
this now we're gonna go to single books
all right hundred thirty you're you
weren't right but you might win okay
here comes one thirty one that lights
gonna turn green when it gets even look
for the middle light 132 here comes one
thirty three turn comes again let me
take a look at the predictions here
afraid you were way over at 400 bucks
sorry let's see somebody I guess Herrick
wins one fifty Oh we did so Robin you
win at 120 because you are under asked
the Ukrainians to help him cheat an
election yeah a lot of people have
written me about this fart gate on
hardball last night there was an obvious
fart and Chris Matthews is calling it
fake news he says it was his cop running
against the the the desk there's no
[ __ ] way listen people are experts
you tuned in people are experts in
sports and they're on TV people are
experts in the stock market I'm an
expert in farting I know when it's apart
and this was a part it was a fart it's
not a cup and I keep improve it I'll do
an experiment how well
listen to the tape Robin Kris so far the
evidence is uncontradicted that the
president used taxpayer dollars to ask
the Ukrainians to help him cheat an
election and the complaint that I've
heard from Republican that's a little
fashion-forward here's a mug the chef
the drunk cello mug as you can see and I
have a similar surface here to the desk
at MSNBC
how do you know that because I watch
that show every night and it's a sleek
slick surface that's how I know you
don't know where that cup was it could
have been sitting on a minute so look
this is what a cop sounds like on a
surface like that you hear that listen
Robert you don't even know if it's the
right kind of mug yeah because they have
a chalo mug on they say that's what a
mug sounds like your scientists pieces
now let's go back to the tape didn't use
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help them cheat an election and the
complaint I've heard from Republicans
I'm a fart scholar I've studied farting
since I don't know college but you don't
have the exact material you can't sneak
a fart pass Howard Stern and what's with
all these shame and embarrassment stop
it do what I do make it part of the show
what an incredible thing to do to become
the head writer on Saturday Night Live I
think it's a title I'm proudest of do
you watch the show religiously every
week I watch a fairly religiously and I
would say that I tend to the next on
Sunday like watch the sketches that
people say are really good do you sit
there and go how the [ __ ] did they let
that on when you see something that's a
real clunker well I I remember that
every single show I ever was head writer
for there was a [ __ ] clunker right so
I appreciation for how hard that show is
I don't know how do clunkers happen in
the sense that you you you you work
these things out ahead of time you don't
have it there's not a lot of ahead of
time right you have a dress rehearsal
yeah some of these sketches go over
pretty big in dress rehearsal right most
of the clunkers were also clunkers a
dress but you just have nothing else
right
and you put them on knowing they're a
clunker well you think okay between
dress and air let's fix it let's do
let's do everything we can all hands on
deck maybe someone could even up their
performance yes the reality is the
things I'm proudest of which is um will
sound negative is like sometimes the
hardest thing to do is to turn a c-minus
into a b-minus right
you know that's tough if it's a c-minus
address it's not gonna be they see
that's why Farley was such an important
part of Saturday Night Live because I
could take a clunker yeah and through
sheer physicality or whatever the [ __ ]
magic he had right he could probably
elevate a c-minus as you put it to maybe
a even an A yeah but he did the guy who
lives in a van down by the river you
knew he could come in and deliver the
goods if you think about it without him
it no one could deliver the goods on
that I also saw somebody posted on
Instagram a video of their
eight-year-old dressed up like that for
Halloween I saw it too and you just go
that's so I mean it's so cool for a
comedy sketch which is a very dark
comedy sketch by the way right Matt
Foley is not a life stock on welfare but
it's so indoors and I think those are
the best things on SNL which is they
kind of work cross generationally which
is a kid could watch it you know when I
was young when I saw Matt Foley and
thought it was so funny and then the
older you get you realize that all the
wonderful details about how bad his life
I've got to admit I always admired
Saturday Night Live because they wanted
to be the anti Carol Burnett so
therefore they would not laugh during
the sketches yeah
but then when I do watch the Matt Foley
sketch and Christina Applegate and David
Spade are just they can barely contain
their laughter yeah
and then when Chris just crashes into
the coffee table with his body yeah and
everyone is just laughing I do love
those moments would you that upset when
the people acting in these sketches
would start to break character and laugh
I I never liked it if it was because the
sketch was bombing right that's Carol
Burnett right yeah but the idea that no
one in the audience would blame
Christina Applegate er David Spade I
mean they're watching it they can't
contain themselves right they're right
next to him
plus the fun thing when you go back and
watch it is you know they're laughing
because they also know the tables coming
right right so they're not they're both
laughing at what's happening in the
present and they're laughing at what's
happening in the future
hey I want to mention that John Hein
this is not my observation but a lot of
the guys came to me do you know about
high energy John know the theory around
here is there are two John Heinz there's
regular John hind that you hear on the
wrap-up show and high energy John right
he's not high energy no no wrap-up show
is slightly higher energy than you get
here but really we're the high energy
how we're hidden with the hind came from
is that sports show he turns into a
completely different what is this boy
let's give John a plug what is these
foods it's called loudmouth loudmouth on
SNY network is the regional Mets Network
so let's give everyone an example of
high energy John yes to here here's John
from his TV show loud mouths this gate
thing it drives me up the wall can we
please put an end to adding a gate to
every single controversy that happens in
professional sports right it was called
Watergate do you know why because the
name of the hotel was the Watergate
Hotel that makes sense all these other
gates it's lazy journalism
he's got opinions he's well don't they
powder
don't they powder his head for that turn
oh yeah it's going - you think that
powder has something in it with it give
some kind of pepe powder that's not the
John I know I can't even imagine him
producing that voice John I mean where
is this energy coming from is this a new
persona you're putting on well on the TV
show when it comes to that sports topic
I was I was pretty fired up for sure but
one thing I do want to clarify and I
think even Jason will admit it I I have
the same energy level on wrap-up as I do
on loudmouths I you do yeah absolutely
I've never seen you that fired up here
when is he ever yelled he's ever yelled
at me like that before
no not even about hitting with the huh
oh I tried even dresses whacky for his
television show he wears Hawaiian shirts
sometimes he once dressed up as Woody
from Toy Story during Halloween and he
even dressed up as a leprechaun what
that is true yeah I'm kind of happy with
the John hi and I am because I like your
natural kind of energy well here humming
I have a different role you know what
you're normal well yeah well I'm in the
back you know I'm working on research
and taking performance when you're on
this sports show yes and you're carrying
on like that see I think it's big
because okay we're looking at the broad
okay John hainan the radio find this
show is different than John hainan S&Y
but we're outside of the office and talk
of you and I talk almost every morning
about TV or politics or sports and did
john honai here in the offices - John
hind that comes onto the show I'm barely
mooses lips I tell people wait John
Hines standing right here hold on this
is dr. Jekyll - mr. real John Hines
stand up this is you know I'm starting
to see there's a new personality I'm
beginning to worry Robin how many times
have we put a mirror under John Hines
to make sure it's breathing and in this
new John Hein it's remarkable but no is
it fair to say this is John Hein gate
this is a completely different person
never left
[Music]
yeah
someday all the lights of London shine
and sky is fading red the blue
I'm kicking through the outer leaves and
wonder where it is you might be going to
then I'm turning back for home you know
I'm feeling so alone I can't believe
[Music]
climbing on the stair I turn around to
see you smiling there in front of me Wow
and if you want it come and get it
crying out loud the lovely that was
given heals never a doubt
[Music]
go ahead failing never
go ahead go ahead
failing now go go ahead
go go ahead
face
Pamela
Beverly
Bella
never love while I'm away
[Music]
I'm gonna go to Jeff to drunk your
boyfriend yes Jeff you're not saying
anything
parrot Bobo yells at me for breaking
news in this show and he's posted on his
twitter cambio with a big picture of him
and you and he's a big user and I want
you to tell them that okay hold on I'll
get them on the line Bobo you're a user
if you're using my picture on your cameo
first of all Jeff what are you bringing
up my [ __ ] name again dude would you
do you mean not to do I how it picks up
there for a long time since there was in
the studio you ask like battle of the
Network nobodies you guys know what
gender would you call up you just for me
about what I'm [ __ ] doing
[Laughter]
gender when you call up just like me
you're ripping me off use our that's
right Fred so what's everyone talking
about I'm confused so here's the bottom
line
right Jeff is upset because his cameo
doesn't get anywhere near the action as
these other guys they don't plug it
either Howard doesn't let listen all the
time like I do
don't yell at me I guess like you to
what hello
[Music]
didn't yell bad for change
you're like a little kid yeah you're the
kid who tells on everyone you just did
you called in to tell I'm Bobo that he's
using a picture of me why don't you call
up and bring up cammy you you
[ __ ]
I never say a word about it [ __ ]
silent I call about topics you stupid
bastard
stay off my [ __ ] radar don't get me
maybe what happens when you get Jeb the
snitch you know why you're freaking out
Jeff you heard high-pitch Eragon here
the other day during the way away and
yeah and he happens to mention that he
made 70 thousand [ __ ] dollars on
cameo I knew that he made that yeah and
you're freaking out how much did you
make on cameo a little over 10 so you
need to make what Eric did for whatever
reason Eric is more popular and Eric is
very entertaining on the air you just
complain about what you're not getting
Howard yeah I just wanted to say Happy
Thanksgiving
same to you - wow this is sad Jeff they
do impression after he turned into the
Hulk yeah hey Jeff we hear from the guy
who just wished everyone Happy
Thanksgiving
I would just like to thank your time
today
sure anybody want to hear from
high-pitch why you make fun of me and
Bobo and being Volvo
what are you talking about Brisbane
I'll follow them you do not on your ass
it's a [ __ ] also just falling down
under holy [ __ ]
trip 1 if you ever want to see Eric
laugh uncontrollably kill him the video
of Jeff falling on the escalator at the
Jimmy Kimmel after-party right Eric
nearly pissed his pants I've never seen
him laugh like this it's something about
Jeff well have a happy Thanksgiving
[Music]
[ __ ] off alright thanks guys bye
everyone
Happy Thanksgiving all Bruce Banner say
no after dude like somebody put a pin in
them whatever okay Sarah good morning
good morning
after watching JD try to use the lighter
on the app I was wondering if he's ever
tried to put in contact why do you say
that I was clipping my nails this
weekend and I was wondering if JD can
clip his own nails because if he doesn't
have the dexterity to light a lighter
how could he use a nail clipper and
Clippers on nails JD is a waste of two
thumbs yet JD can you work a nail
clipper I was thinking
JD can you work a nail clipper yes I can
work a nail clipper I cut my nails this
weekend what about you don't wear
contacts do you I did in high school but
not anymore
and you were able to put him in uh yeah
uh wondering I hate it putting it taking
them off and putting them in so that's
one reason I just what's stable classes
can you tie your own shoes did you have
to make like the baby like way of doing
it or can you do it with a single loop
a single loop I don't know what other
words there's two ways of tying your
shoes when you're a little kid they
first teach you to make two loops and
then tie yeah
but then when you become a little more
grown-up you make one loop and then you
wrap the thing around it and then you
don't I'm saying I mean I make two loops
I go under it he does the baby wake up
you don't know the adult way right I
just tie my shoes what is he wearing a
bowtie for today's he's part of the high
pitch hair away and he'll be actually
putting the books on the scale way looks
handsome today he looks good thank you
like my boy maybe the bowtie is his luck
can you light a match like from a
matchbook I think so yeah I don't I
haven't really done it but you couldn't
I'll try but I don't want to set
anything off I don't I mean like those
paper matches in the little books yeah I
don't think you can do it we should to
do a game what can JD do well let's look
up all the things you need your thumb
for because you can't tie his shoes like
a grown-up can you snap your fingers
nice crisp sound yeah hey Wolfie what's
up a couple things first did you ask Amy
about the way that he ties his shoes
because when I observed in that day he
did something really weird he touched on
loops into the side of the shoes next to
his ankles I've never seen that before
that was when the laces of my shoes were
too long and I was stepping on them I
don't have that anymore
why don't you double knot it I don't
like the double knot you want me to
teach you the grown-up way - I'm being
serious so I'll teach you today I'm fine
can you tie a tie oh I do not in a hat I
tie hey JD could you split a piece of
firewood with an axe probably not now
could you uh did you drive a nail into a
board using a hammer he's ignoring you
he said what I can't listen and chew gum
at the same time
now
I'm gonna play a couple of things that
have been happening including Sal's
weird pronunciations you know the word
Villa I have a villa in France perhaps
you'd say he calls it a villa I hate to
say this
you're wrong but both in Italian get out
of here you're in America [ __ ] first
of all I'll tell you what you're not
from Italy you didn't grow up in Italy
you've never been in Italy I've been to
yeah okay here's south from the wrap-up
show yesterday listen to this guy women
love men who are successful so you have
to play the success card you have to you
have to paint the big picture 90% of the
time a woman is not gonna be attracted
to the average guy right off the bat but
if you give her a reason like you have a
man chin like you have a place in the
Hamptons like you have a villa in Italy
stuff that most likely she won't see
Mila when guys like what do you have in
Italy I thought he was saying like
you're really exaggerating I'm gonna get
you because you seem like a bright guy
me honestly ma'am I think I'm a bright
guy but in Italy they say Vilas they say
Venice table ulica forget Sal being an
idiot with the word Vila okay
listen to this this is from the wrap-up
show don't get caught up in what the
content is just do you remember what
that whole Jim Jones thing was about
yeah he had an occult he gave all these
people cool lane they drop dead weight
he had what he had this a cult I think
it's called an occult right they say a
cult how'd you learn how to say that
wrong well a cult
I heard then it was cult not a cult but
an occult is I think it's a comedy it's
like satanic groups there are cults but
I thought it's the same thing I long as
it's a group sound you're do you ever
read you ever ever like take an interest
in anything so busily saying a cult
they're not saying a cult they're saying
a and then a word see you LT cult a cult
and then there is the occult the occult
or a cult is holy cow when I say occult
OC OC cou LT whatever it is and you hear
people say in a cult
I'm not always thinking it's occult no I
never I never distinguish the difference
between a cult and a cult when you win
only chow where did you grow up man and
don't give me this [ __ ] home
in Italy yeah because when you know
loser like come to my Vila you know I
says that like from Transylvania I want
you to come to my view yeah yes by the
way I just heard on the wrap-up show
Papa fooi has some small desire to throw
another first pitch what yes what was
like what I can't imagine why he'd want
to revisit the single most humiliating
moment in his life he thinks if he goes
out and throws another pitch it'll make
this one go away right this one is never
going away by the way I don't think that
Robin but a lot of people around me
you're trying to convince me of that
because they want to see me make a fool
of myself there's no upside because Gary
if you even throw a perfect pitch
they're still gonna go but look at his
first time he did it I had that thought
for like a half a second on the wrap-up
show and then I was over it in ten
minutes but the guys on the show were
like no imagine the redemption you go
out there and you do it I go it's just
another reason for them to show the
first place no what were you thinking
when you were kind of contemplating
throwing the first pitch were you having
a fantasy that you'd go out there and
throw a great pitch and all would be
forgiven if you want to consider the
second time trying it he did do it again
on Jimmy Kimmel's television show he
hits a woman in the audience with the
ball in the head I did it in high heels
on the Jimmy Kimmel show and had no
problem
putting in Jimmy's glove practice I
don't throw balls I don't do anything
Gary you were really mad at Jimmy Kimmel
for making you do that right he kind of
put you on why did you hit him not that
woman ten years later news anchors are
still goofing on Gary never gonna give
that up
anchor Raul Martinez showed tape of
himself throwing out the first pitch
another anchor then mentioned Gary's
pitch so even when these guys are just
talking about something completely other
than Gary Gary makes his way look at the
off-speed right
over the plate he followed the howard
stern show baba booey had one of the
greatest for images ever two or three
hops before it got to the thanks bowl
that was just recently well not only was
it two or three hops it went away from
the home plate it trailed awesome oh I
meant to do that
a football player named Denard Robinson
botched his first pitch at news anchor
reference Baba Booey when discussing the
pitch it's amazing how hard that is to
do one bad step there and all of a
sudden your Baba Booey Gary hates that
anchors goof on him right yeah I just
think that all these guys are you know
big shots until like you know even Robin
I'd like to see you go out in front of a
whole crowd not that you said you could
do it but like everybody's a big shot
when they're on the air at a recent
Chicago White Sox game an employee at
the ballpark was given a chance to throw
out the first pitch he accidentally hit
a cameraman right in front of her
of course Gary's pitch was mentioned in
this story it's like it one more time
releases just a little bit late it
doesn't look that bad
Howard Stern's producer Gary Dell'Abate
back today he threw one that was one for
the ages - just real awful he practiced
and practice and under pressure I mean
that'll be part of your obituary when
you die the world shittiest picture well
don't you believe it would be in his
obituary I'm not sure I think it would
be I think people would feel bad enough
to keep it out of it though but they say
it is a fun thing like hey you know
Howard Stern's longtime producer Gary
bababooey Dell'Abate known for not only
his work on the radio but also for his
legendary bad pitch when he threw out
the first pitch in a Mets game yeah I
think it will could you die Gary so we
can say oh it'll be like people who
throw horrible pitches across America in
his honor are called the bobble buoys
like there might even be a cult my Met
was telling me he really thinks Gary
should throw the first pitch what Home
Office is pulling for him honestly it
would be the funnest coolest thing ever
if Gary did it are you saying it because
you want to see him fail or are you
saying that would be great that would be
funny but I would also like to see him
succeed too I think it would be cool I
think would be great for this it would
be big
so what do you think you should do so he
shouldn't do it again really yeah
because I think he's gonna do it really
really well and then he's gonna just
brag about and gloat that he did it well
and he made a mistake I think he should
definitely not do it I would but you
[ __ ] up as you succeeding this is so
much fun that Gary [ __ ] it up that
right did it well then it would
dissipate like when you see a clown of
those at a circus if it doesn't [ __ ] up
and fall down and slip you're not
laughing
right but I don't think anybody will
ever remember Gary throwing a good pitch
I agree Robin but the thing is Gary Gary
Howard just said that and now to say oh
I could do it Gary said that four years
before this pitch you said that he was
acting like a big shot before his first
yeah yeah that's what Gary fails to
realize you said it Gary you said you
could do it you said I threw like a girl
and Jason threw like a girl and we were
incompetent right and then you went out
there and made the biggest [ __ ] out
of yourself like he used to goof on the
way you threw yes I think I could pitch
better than Gary and I've never thrown a
ball in my life Touche to me
to myself so you're saying Gary no
longer can big bragging in the halls how
he's so great and not at all not only
dares to you in a field which was a
tremendous amount of pressure okay I'll
give him that much then jimmy kimmel a
small little studio right what does he
hit he hits a lady out of all people I
mean in the head yeah there was a giant
stage there he could have went over them
he hit a poor helpless lady in the head
she's near Jimmy Kimmel she was in
Wisconsin is that way yeah
but for now the Howard Stern Show